المره الاولى التي يتمكن المواطنون من
دخول محيط مستشفى الرنتيسي في شارع النصر
هذا المحيط الذي شهد اشتباكات عنيفه
وضراوة الابراج السكنيه كباقي
المناطق في قطاع
غزه يعني هذا محيط ايضا الرنتيسي كما
تشاهدون
هنا العمائر السكنيه
والمنازل للا منزل صالح في هذه
المنطقه محيط مستشفى الرنتيسي محيط محطم
عن بكره ابي حتى المستشفيات والعيادات
الصحيه لم تسلم من عدوان الاحتلال ولم
تسلم من من اجرامه وبطشه منطقه رنتيس
ومنطقه الشيخ رضوان بشكل عام منطقه وكانها
زلزال مدمر هذا الحي باكمله اصبح حيا
مدمرا كل ما فيه سقط نتيجه اله البطشه
الاسرائيليه هذه مربعات كامله لم نعد نعرف
تضاريسها ويبدو ان هذا هو مستشفى الرنتيسي
او محيط مستشفى
الرنتيسي
هنا ايضا جثمان شهيد كما تشاهدون الان هذا
جثمان شهيد قت
ان هذه كومه من صناديق الذخيره
الاسرائيليه في محيط المستشفى التي
استنفذت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي والقت
بها هنا كما تشاهدونها الان كميه الذخائر
الملقاه في هذه
المنطقه والصناديق
الفارغه
هذا مربع المنازل قد دمرته قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ايضا خلال تمركزها في مستشفى
الرنتيسي هذه المنازل او عشرات المنازل
جميعها سوتها
بالارض هذا مستشفى النصر للاطفال قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ايضا دمرته بالكامل
كما تشاهدونه في هذه الخلفيه هذا المستشفى
الذي يخدم مئات الاف الاطفال في هذه
المنطقه و بمقابله مستشفى العيون وايضا هو
المستشفى الوحيد لامراض العيون في محافظه
غزه كما تشاهدون هو الان مدمرا تدميرا
كبيرا وبجواره مستشفى الرنتيسي اغلب
المبان كلياتها تجرف مستشفى النصر هنا
الاطفال كلياتها اختفت يعني كانت في هنا
مستشفى واختفت
الشوارع اختلفت يعني كانت في ازاحات في
الشوارع تفحير في كل مكان الدمار يعني عام
على كل شي حتى يعني حركه الشارع الطبيعيه
اختلفت مستويات الشوارع اختلفت تجريف بشكل
كبير جدا يعني يمكن نز اكثر من 10 15 متر
في الارض الطبيعيه قديش غزه بدها بس ترجع
غ
سنه سه احكيلي احكيلي احكيلي كيف شايف حجم
الدمار في هذه المنطقه ضل غز راحت غز مسحت
غز ضل غز طب في مبرر شايف اهداف
المستشفيات ولا شيء في ولا شيء كلها بنيان
واراضي ودور وكسرت ومستشفيات ومدارس
وتعليم راح ايش امنياتكم في العام القادم
ما طل امنيه خلص انتهت غزه مقبره
صارت ما خلوش ولا حجر ولا شجر ولا بشر
كلنا انتهكوا كل حرومات الدنيا اخترقوا كل
القوانين الدوليه عملوا في الوطن العربي
كوم وفي غزه كوم ثاني احنا هنا اليوم بخوض
معركه امه كامله ونسال الله عز وجل انه
يثبت الناس ويرجعها على دورها وعلى
مساكنها ويلم شملها هذا الدمار كله ان شاء
الله يكون عباره عن حجاره بتسقط ولكن
العزيمه زي الحديده باذن
الله